so livermorium was first made in around
2000 it was made in calcium 48 plus
curium 248 reaction we've since made
four different isotopes of livermorium
they all have tens of milliseconds
half-lives so they're pretty short-lived
so unfortunately I can't show you a
bottle it was a very interesting process
to name these elements when we got
permission to name 114 and 116 we were
naming two elements at once only of
course began discussions with our
Russian colleagues and reached a
consensus on these names flerovium for
for 114 and livermorium for 116 we chose
the memoriam because we could not
discover enough elements to name one
after everybody who is important in
these kinds of experiments there were
many many scientists here at Livermore
and some have retired even passed away
who were involved in heavy element
research so we couldn't Nate we couldn't
discover enough elements a name after
every single person so we chose a
livermorium to honor all those people
honor the institution here and the city
of Livermore we thought that was an
appropriate way to kind of recognize all
of all of the scientists involved in
that work you spent some time in the
community on itv2 Orchestra no value you
now know people how has that decision
they were saved by the institution of
the paper a little more than a-- been
outstanding are the mayor of Livermore
is is a water chemist so he understands
chemistry he was ecstatic that this
can't came about he understood the
significance of the new element and in
that particular name on the periodic
table he's been very supportive we have
a liver morning day now which is in late
May they've also named a
a part of a Park Plaza in downtown
Livermore and livermorium Plaza so
they've been very supported very
ecstatic about it and and understand I
think the community here because lab is
here you know it's people are much maybe
a little more scientific scientifically
understanding or scientifically literate
so they understand the significance of
it so it's been nothing but supportive
for for that element so one of the
predicted properties because it's in
group 16 it's in this column of the
periodic table where many of the
hydrogen compounds of that group are
very smelly so think about hydrogen
sulfide rotten eggs smell hydrogen
selenide 8 a.m. yes rhenium is notorious
for for being very smelly rotten garlic
or something like that it's described at
Telluride the Telluride tellurium is
also very strong so if you if you think
about the going down that column of the
periodic table you might say that
livermorium is maybe the smelliest
element of a periodic table it would be
very difficult to verify because we
haven't made the hydrogen compound of it
we the isotopes as I mentioned are 10
millisecond long so it's very difficult
and in addition you probably wouldn't
want to smell it because it's
radioactive and you wouldn't want to
actually put your nose on and saw it
hydrogen sulfide won't won't hurt you
it'll hurt you and you know strong
enough concentrations but you everyone
smelled rotten eggs
before you wouldn't want to do that with
livermorium so let's get going and see
whether the experiment is so as we go
along here the ions are going faster
faster and faster
all the time inside the tube here you
see such a target wheel which is mounted
on the axis of this motor here it's any
like this in the beam